biro biro
hello reject nation leg Alva here with
the lovely and talented Stacy Howard hey
you it's so Howard 2012 on Twitter and
Instagram part of hit-or-miss movies is
a winner on the team match for Collider
videos no down and a singles match [ __ ]
yeah she is bomb diggity with movie
knowledge but hey Stacy what that we
can't watch a movie trailer right now
why because why have gotten reclaim what
up the wazoo to check out some video a
guy made named sad greg alba sad greg
alba and that's just who you are yes my
biopic yeah that i personally have a pen
yeah this is the real greg we're about
to see is this when you cry after sex
i cried during after occasionally before
sex okay this i i'm assuming based off
of video pretty cool features like it
yes i am second time through it I can't
wait to see what this is great I hope
it's like one of those like Kevin sighs
you said that athlete with you I really
don't know that would be fantastic
alright let's check it out before when
you just mentioned it's over wireless
where inspire me to you're doing a piece
of delivery stuff and all that and then
at the I actually I love the invisible
oh I want to scream
oh [ __ ] I've always thought I had a
meeting today oh that was fantastic
yes oh wow yes just what we wanted
whoo-hoo corvax Oh quarterback you have
earned yourself a subscription service
for that
oh but for Tyrell Magnus he does funny
moments compilation no that's funny
because there are plenty of times when
I'm editing I'll see what I'm listening
especially with John talking I have like
this sad listening face it's like my
company how you feel yep resting
[ __ ]
I do yeah yeah because you really are
that you know that's like that yeah
everything I remember bananas man I've
been out with you you do have like that
serious thank you yeah I'm thinking yeah
and then some of my thinking yeah it
looks like a sadness sadness good call
good call core vac I wanted to see what
you look like now and this is a video
about me I wanted to take some time to
do a little thing just for a subscriber
a follower so on our patreon if you
pledge a certain amount you get a patron
of a shout out and one of our highest
pleasures a woman named Rosa Parra we're
now this all about this won't be for her
she wants this shout out to be for her
daughter Cassandra and I should have
deserved members in it
Cassandra not if you see Rosa para loves
John Humphrey he is a very lovable teddy
bear she wants to write in like no one's
business
Wow now I
know if I should keep that in this video
because Cassandra is just turned 12
today so I said you know what for you
Rosa I will gladly give Cassandra a
happy birthday shout-out because
apparently Cassandra is a follower of
the channel as well happy birthday to
you Cassandra twelve years old that's
one step closer to 13 meaning you're one
step closer to worry
yes if I said that it would be really
weird oh you're a girl now your breasts
are a little tender they're growing it's
fine everything's going to be fine
just it's okay don't freak out okay
thank you for that Stacy yeah see Rosa
loves John because Sondra Rosa has
specified twice that she prefers me over
John Oh rivalry rivalry I tell you who I
prefer meter okay I know your breasts
are a little hanger right now you're
just discovering your body it's gonna be
all right
hello darkness my old friend I've come
to talk that's the quick little video
war boats and Stacy's on the new set I'm
in the queen bee queen and the surgeon
chair hey speaking of Cersei we got to
move on to the game of Thrones
subscribe to the real reject click that
notification bell so Howard 2012's hours
ESCO sampling see Olivia's my initial oh
my girlfriend's named Olivia really good
in that out of inner memory check your
back up